Hey everyone, we are in the chapter 12 problems.
I'm going to be going through a series of questions here.
From the material that you've been covering, I'm going to look at how we answer some of these questions.
Let's go ahead and jump into our first question.
And this says we have a scenario.
Your firm requires a low margin substitute product to your existing line.
And what pricing strategy should you use to avoid cannibalizing your own sales?
So here we have two substitute products we're trying to price so to avoid any cannibalization.
So if we price too low in one good, then we're going to steal sales from the other good by doing so.
So what we want to do here is actually raise our prices.
This helps reduce any overlap and preserves our margins.
Especially we want to raise the price on the more price sensitive, I.e.
elastic product since buyers are more likely to switch away because it's already cheap.
Or that is if it's already cheap.
So we're going to be looking at these answers and we're going to be going with C as our answer.
Raise prices on both, especially on the more elastic low margin product.
All right, next question.
Scenario again.  All right, after acquiring a complementary product, you need to adjust your price or your pricing to increase joint demand.
What should you do?
So with compliments is the exact, it's the opposite of, of what we saw with substitutes here.
Demand for one good increases when demand for the other increases.
So what we want to do is actually lower the prices on both of those.
So we're trying to create joint consumption as opposed to separate consumption.
So we could bundle these.
That would make it very attractive.
But we're not talking about bundling this chapter.
So instead what we're going to be looking at is actually just lowering the price on both of those goods to sell them.
We do have the word bundle in there, but.
But it looks like a bundle.
When we start to lower both the price on the good.
It's not a true bundle in the essence or the, or the sense of the word bundle.
All right, but that's what we're trying to do.
So we lower the price on both goods.
It looks more attractive to consumers as opposed to what the substitutes do where you're trying to avoid cannibalization.
Okay, let's move to our next question.
A ski resort has fixed weekend capacity.
What should it consider when setting prices?
All right, so if they have fixed capacity, we know that they can't go above a certain amount of ski lift tickets or whatever it is.
People almost like I don't know.
So what we're looking at here is trying to focus on a price that allows us to fill to that capacity.
So we're going to set prices to fill capacity guided by demand and short run marginal cost.  So that's our answer.
But let's look at some explanation behind that.
Let's suppose that this ski resort estimated their demand to look something like this.
Quantity equals 5000 minus 5p and they have capacity.
I'm going to set this equal to 4,000.
So this is how many people that they can have at their ski resort in a given weekend.
And they know what their demand looks like given this demand function here.
So to figure out how to set the exact price that they want to filter that capacity, we what we're going to do is set our demand 5,000 minus 5p equal to our capacity constraint and then we'll solve out for what price happens to be.
Pull the 4000 over that gives me 1000.
Pull the minus 5p over to the other side and that gives me 5p.
Solve down for price.
So price in this case not 2000 price is going to be just 200.
Let me write it correctly.
So they're going to price each sku bif ticket or whatever it is that they're pricing.
And at 200, if they price under that, then they're going to have over extended the amount of people that can come in.
If they price above that then they're going to have excess capacity.
So in that case they're not actually getting to the point where they're just feeling to that capacity.
So that's how we look at a question like that one.
Next question.  The stadium has.
So this looks a lot like what we were just talking about.
Stadium has a fixed seating capacity of 5,000 seats.
Demand for tickets is estimated by Q equals 6,000 minus 10 P.
The marginal cost is $10 per ticket.
We're not really, we don't really care about that because we're trying to fill 2 capacity.
So we're trying to fill out that stadium.
What price should they charge here?
What we're looking at is again what we just did.
So we're going to set our quantity demand or excuse me, our demand 6,000 minus 10p equal to the capacity that we have.  Solve this out.
This is going to give me 1000 on this side, going to get 10p on the other side.
So price is equal to $100.
So that's how we price to fill to capacity.
Now we'll talk about this a Little bit more.
When we get to price discrimination, we talk about two part tariffs.
Firms or stadiums in particular might sell tickets that deal with two part tariffs in which they do sell an access the right to buy a seat and then they sell you the season tickets.
So that may happen, but in this particular case we're just looking at how you can feel to capacity given the constraints that we have.
All right, which of the following is most important when pricing and anticipation of future demand.
So we're looking ahead, trying to figure out what we're going to be doing here.
So we're looking forward, we're not looking backwards.
So our forecast, and that's, I mean that's pretty indicative future demand there, pretty indicative that we're looking at some kind of forecast.
And with that forecast we're going to be looking at kind of a few things that we want to keep in mind.
How much will consumers be willing to pay or, or want at different prices?
What kind of seasonal trends we might have?
Are there any other type of economic shifts that are going to occur in like in the broader economy?
Any type of market events that may occur and then what type of inventory are we looking to hold or we looking to have any type of promotions that go on?
So when we're trying to anticipate that future demand, we want to forecast those different changes in consumer demand.
And remember when we talked about forecasting, we can always use historical data, but sometimes it's good to use simulations to figure out what your demand might look like.
So you might estimate a demand curve to look like that based on historical data.
But then you also want to consider what could happen, what can happen like this.
So you might get multiple demand curves based off the simulations that you run.
That is, you alter different things inside of the economy to figure out where your demand is going to look like.
And then you could take the expected value of all of those simulations to get probably a better idea of what your demand is going to be looking like.
Alright, let's move on to our next question.
Your advertising campaign has successfully increased brand loyalty.
What likely happens to your pricing power?
All right, so whenever you have a successful advertising campaign, what you're really doing here is you're building that brand loyalty and you're making your consumers less sensitive to price changes as they become inelastic as opposed to being elastic.
So this is going to give you more pricing power in the firm.
It's going to allow you to charge higher prices.
So here your demand becomes less elastic, I.e.
it becomes more inelastic.
And so you can raise those prices on your goods.
All right, next question.
According to prospect theory, and this deals with psychological pricing, what effect should you expect when consumers perceive a price increase as a loss?
So increase in prospect theory, particular psychological pricing.
Prospect theory, what we look at is, or what we try to think about is people are actually perceiving the loss as they actually dislike the loss more than they like the actual equivalent gain.
So if I lose $2 people under prospect theory, it's actually worse than if I had gained $2.
Alright, so that's how prospect theory views things.
So that right there is going to drive an overreaction and it's going to cause those losses to feel larger than those gains.
So that's why D is going to be our answer.
So firms here, you got to frame that price increase.
If you're doing this, you need to frame that price increase carefully or make a bundle out of goods perhaps.
So that way people perceive the gains a little bit better than what they otherwise would.
A streaming service increases its monthly rate by $2 to reduce any customer churn.
It frames this Change as a $24 annual improvement package.
What concept is being applied?
Well, I mean, we kind of already gave it away by saying it frames.
And we know that framing a loss as a gain is going to be our answer.
But what we're looking at here, again framing is again in psychological pricing, it's a strategy that we use particularly because it comes out of prospect theory is a strategy that we use because people react differently depending on how the information is presented to them.
Okay, so in here, what we're looking at, a $2 price increase sounds like a loss.
So you reframe that to say $24 annual improvement package.
So it seems like it's less painful over an entire year versus looking at that $2 monthly hike.
So I mean, think about when you, when you go buy things that you can buy on a monthly basis versus things that they say we're going to charge you, let's say 999 per month or over the course of a year, we're going to just one lump sum, charge you whatever it is, $120.
So it may seem like more perceived benefit, less of a loss if you frame it that way as opposed to on a monthly basis where you see it constantly.
So this one is going to be softening that negative emotional response simply by reframing it in a different way.
So that's how we are going to be answering that question.
And that is all of our questions coming out of chapter number 12.
Hope you've enjoyed it.